[Music]
are you an illustrator
yes
you're very muddy i was attacked by one
and a half tonne bull oh
i'm prepared to offer you a staff
position you capture something of a cat
perhaps because you yourself are an
outcast
i do to provide for the five hungry and
precocious sisters that i live at home
with
and we've had a governess i think you're
the first person to see the cats are
ridiculous
frightened
and brave
like us
miss richardson has had an incredibly
positive effect on this family were you
painting something
here's something funny miss wayne not at
all
[Music]
the cat man
a whole cat world
they will tumble and communicate with us
in our own language did you say that
they would turn blue yes of course wow
what's going on in that funny little
head of yours
[Music]
electricity
okay louie i'm worried about you
i feel
[Music]
electricity
[Music]
mr wayne i have been called here because
your sister is concerned for your health
you have squandered it on wretched cats
and on a willful doomed tainted romance
how you've managed to conjure images of
such delight
at such a dark time
i don't know
just
remember i have hard things get
however much you feel like you're
struggling
the world is full of beauty
and it's up to you to capture it only
and to share it with as many people as
you can
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you